all right um welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules and
Logistics uh first of all please mute
yourself during the talk but if you have
questions you can unmute and ask
questions or use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
Q&A session at the end second today's
ddps seminar is open to external
audiences um so no classified discussion
uh finally The Talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our YouTube
channel um that's about it now let me
briefly introduce our speaker today um
it is an honor to host Dr elnas rayan
Who is a postdoctoral fellow at the
department of aerospace engineering at
University of Michigan she received her
PhD in mechanical engineering from
Kansas State University in
2020 um with her dissertation focused on
stabilization of projection based R
models for Real Time prediction of
Dynamics in strongly nonlinear uh
compressible flow applications during
her post-doctoral experience at
University of Michigan she has been
working with Professor Kik uh Dura Sami
uh at the computational aeroscience lab
on surrogate modeling and non-intrusive
model model reduction in complex systems
using system identification and machine
learning today elnas will present an
exciting topic which is uh datadriven uh
balancing trans
Transformations uh for predictive model
order reduction I'm sure uh we will hear
an exciting talk today um but before I
pass the button let me ask a couple of
questions to elas um so that we get to
know her better and make this seminar
somewhat informal um okay here the
question goes
um obviously you are passionate about
datadriven modeling in general is there
any moment in your life when you realize
that wow this is it this is the field I
would like to commit my
career um well first of all uh thank you
so much for the introduction Dr Choy and
regarding the question I should say that
um yes I guess when I realized the vast
application of mod uction uh in many
query applications uh and how these
methods can accelerate uh applications
uh like monery quantification and design
optimization I was really uh Amazed by
that and I thought that um this this
should be the topic that I should pursue
uh in my future career awesome awesome
okay the floor is
yours okay uh thank you so much uh I'm
very glad to have the opportunity uh to
um uh be here in this seminar today and
uh talk about uh our studies on balanced
truncation um so first and foremost uh
let me uh introduce uh the air force
center of excellence on multifidelity
modeling of uh rocket combustion
Dynamics uh which is a collaboration
between five different universities on
um advancement of model reduction
methods for uh complex systems and uh
what I'm going to talk about in uh
today's um presentation is mainly part
of our studies on mod reduction in
linear systems H they there have been
amazing uh developments in this group on
other topics as well under this uh
project including basis adaptation
operator inference methods and neural
network based drums that uh you can uh
check out here if you are interested and
with that um let's get started um so as
you know reduced order modeling
techniques are um uh have have emerged
to substitute a high fidelity simulation
in uh many query applications uh in
which we need to repetitively uh compute
the quantities of interest for tens of
thousands of times and so using the
highy simulations uh some with at least
millions of degrees of freedom in these
applications would be
infeasible um mod reduction methods uh
fall under two categories U intrusive
and non-intrusive uh intr intrusive
methods um need access to the governing
equations and nonintrusive methods
mainly rely on data and they don't need
access to the governing equations and
now if you're familiar with Mod
reduction you know that sorry projection
based mod reduction methods um are being
applied to problems of increasing
increasing complexity uh these days such
as the examples that I've shown in these
uh pictures uh and uh this uh is enabled
only by making major improvements in the
standard uh projection based model
reduction framework work so let's first
take a very quick look at the standard
process for projection based ROMs um in
which let's consider this um set of
generic equations as our High Fidelity
model uh what we do is that we first use
data to uh compute a low dimensional to
obtain a low dimensional space using a
dimensiona reduction method um for
example proper orthogonal decomposition
is a popular choice and so let's say the
PD modes that are also called the trial
Subspace here are represent Ed by matrix
V and then we use a test Subspace W to
project the governing equations onto the
lower dimensional space and in garan
projection the test and trial subspaces
are the same now there are certain
limitations in this Standard Process um
and specifically pin procedure that
prevents application of the standard
process to uh complex problems like this
um uh one of the limitations is that P
is a linear dimensionality reduction
method so uh if you're if if we are
dealing with strongly nonlinear uh
problems uh then we're going to need a
lot of modes to capture the true
Dynamics and that defeats the purpose of
mod reduction and on the other hand pod
is biased towards the most energetic
modes uh so for example in control
applications uh we are uh mainly
interested in the most controllable
modes rather than the most energetic
modes uh so pod is only suitable for
these applications if uh the most
controllable modes are also the most
energetic modes we have similar uh
issues with observability as well for
example if you're interested in
capturing acoustic modes that do not
contain a lot of energy uh then uh these
modes these features will be these waves
will be tranced through the standard pod
uh
process um and another limitation with
the standard P ging procedure is that if
the jauan Matrix of the high FY model is
not symmetric which is the case in many
uh complex applications uh the G method
does not necessarily Preserve
um stability through model
reduction um now there have been many
methods that are developed in the uh
past years uh to uh address these
limitations in the standard projection
based model reduction methods and I
believe these methods fall under these
categories that I have mentioned here um
the first thing that we can do is to uh
move away from the linear dimensionality
method and um use a nonlinear manifold
uh uh that is that could be for example
constructed by Auto encoders Neal
networks or uh to adapt the P bases um
in time to get a piecewise linear uh
Subspace um another U set of methods are
uh developed to promote symmetry in ROM
equations so that uh St stability is
preserved through model reduction we
also have ROM stabilization techniques
and closure modeling that uh basically
improve uh the reduced order models by
modifying the ROM equations and also
hyper reduction which is outside of the
scope of the talk
um now for uh specifically for linear
systems balance truncation developed by
Mur 1981 is also a projection based mod
reduction method that um um addresses
the limitations of the standard pod glin
projection uh mainly by taking the first
two approaches here um so this consider
a linear time invariance system as shown
here in Balance ration we are still
looking for hierarchical model
representation but the definition of
hierarchy balance transation is is
different from po so in Balance
truncation uh instead of uh ordering the
modes from the most energetic to the
least energetic we would like as we do
in pu we would like to order the modes
from the most controllable and
observable to the least controllable and
observable and um in the next um I guess
U 50 minutes we'll see how we can do
that um so uh first things first I'll go
through uh some basic system theoretic
uh topics that we need to understand uh
balance tration and its data driven
version system realization algorithm and
uh then I we talk about so for example
external description internal
description and system realization are
the foundations for the a system
realization algorithm and reability and
observability and system gramians are
required uh to understand the balance
truncation um and after talking about
these algorithms we'll uh see the
results of applying igen system
realization algorithm to two numerical
experiments a one dimensional reacting
flow problem and an eror acoustic
prediction problem and uh here I will
also further introduce some additional
methods uh to uh reduce the offline cost
of construction of ROMs by er er so now
what is the external description U there
are two ways to describe a system
external description and internal
description external description of a
system is mainly concerned with its
input output Behavior so let's consider
a system to be like a blackbox when we
look at this blackbox from outside the
only uh things that we can see are the
input signal that we are applying to the
system and the output generated by the
system in response to that input uh
which is probably measured by some um
sensors um and uh this is what happens
in many real world applications in which
we don't have access to the uh governing
equations and we don't know what's going
on inside this uh black blackbox uh so
external description uh is uh basically
uh the mapping s from the inputs U to
the outputs Y and for discrete time
system it's given by this equation here
that um takes this shape in Matrix form
and this uh Matrix at the in the middle
of the slide is actually a waiting
Matrix that uh identifies how the
outputs depend on the inputs at
different time steps now we want to see
how we can obtain this mapping and also
whether we can use this mapping and the
external description to understand
what's going on ins inside this uh black
box and of course the answer is yes um
so for a linear time invariance system
uh the U each row in that rating Matrix
in the external description can be
described by a sequence of constant uh
matrices this sequence is also called
the sequence of uh Mark of parameters so
for a linear time in variant and causal
system and by CA all we mean the output
at the current time step depends on the
inputs at the current and the past time
steps and not the future time steps so
for a system under these conditions this
sequence of markof parameters is given
by the response of the uh system to unit
impulse so it can be obtained in a
datadriven manner and each of these uh
blocks in this sequence are uh P bym
matrices where p is the number of
outputs and M is the number of inputs so
under these conditions uh the U um
impulse response snapshots of the system
basically identify the input output
Behavior or the external description of
the
system now U as I mentioned another way
to uh describe the system is through the
internal description this is also called
State space representation uh which uh
may be U more familiar uh to you and uh
for discrete time system the internal
description is given by a set of
difference equations that's shown here
which has this exact solution at the
bottom of the uh slide um and and so
here the uh system is no longer a
blackbox um so this besides the inputs
and outputs we also have information
about the state and the governing
equations and this is the output
equation here where where see is the
output map that uh identifies the how
the system interacts with the
surroundings and du is the fifth through
term in the exact solution here x k0 is
the initial condition and here B is the
input map and a is the Dynamics Matrix
and of course if the system matrices are
constant with respect to time we have a
linear time invariance
system now we can uh use this exact
solution of the um uh sa space
representation to show that this
equation at the bottom of the slide is
actually the impulse response of the
system now why do I mention this here
the reason is that U later when I when I
explain I system realization algorithm I
will refer to this expression here as
the impulse response or the sequence of
markof parameter
and um I'd like you to you to see why
this is the sequence of Mark of
parameters so simply substitute unit
impulse for U in the exact solution and
substitute X in the output equation and
U you'll get the impulse response of the
system at each time step now as I
mentioned the sequence of Mark of
parameters for a linear time invariance
system is given by the impulse response
so if you're convinced that this is the
impulse response of the system then we
can go ahead and use this expression to
obtain each of the mark of parameters in
this uh sequence in terms of the system
matrices so for example at at the first
time step k equals zero and the first
block would be D then at the second time
step k equals 1 the second block would
be CB and so on so
forth uh now I'd like to mention here
that the system transfer function which
is actually the llos transform of the
impulse response of the system and uh of
course the mark of parameters are
invariant under coordinate
transformation which means that later in
Balance truncation when we transform the
system to another coordinates these
quantities remain
unchanged um now system uh the system
realization theory is uh the foundation
uh for uh the data driven version of
balance truncation that we are mainly
focused on uh in this work U and as I
mentioned in many engineering
applications we do not have access to
the governing equations or we do have
access to the equations but we want to
build a lower dimensional representation
for the system and system realization
uses the external description or the
input output behavior of the system to
build the internal description or uh the
state space representation so again
let's say the system is like a blackbox
and the only information that we have is
about the inputs and sensor measurements
we want to know uh if we can use that
information to identify the governing
equations now there there are multiple
ways to do this but we are here
specifically focused on a on taking a U
System um theoretic approach that
resembles close connections with
balanced truncation that comes with
stability guarantees and so the problem
is to uh is that given the external
description from simulations and
experiments uh we want to identify the
internal
description and I'd also like to mention
here that um there are infinitely many
realizations for a system them uh but we
are interested um and these realizations
would give us the same output for a
specific input but we are interested in
the realization that that can do this
task with the minimum number of degrees
of freedom and that's called the minimum
realization and the a system realization
algorithm is a way to construct this
minimum
realization uh so the a system
realization algorithm mainly uh relies
on a matrix that is called Handel Matrix
U this Matrix that's shown here if
assemble a matrix by U with the impulse
response or the sequence of Markov
parameters uh as its rows then uh this
Matrix is called the hand Handel Matrix
and it's uh plays a key role in model
reduction of linear systems as we will
see uh so only two topics are left here
the reachability and observability um
and also the system gramians um before
we can uh talk about balance truncation
now what is
reachability yeah what is reachability a
system is reachable if all of it States
can be uh excited by the control action
or in other words uh if the impact of
the control signal uh can reach all of
the states in the system then that
system is reachable and for a linear
time invariant system reachability
reduces to an algebraic definition uh
that's um basically identified by this
Matrix here which is called The
reachability Matrix and L I system is
reachable if and only if uh the rank of
this Matrix is equal to the order of the
system n uh and observability on the
other hand determines whether um the all
of the states in the system are
accessible through the output for
example if the output of the system
remains unchanged U with respect to
variations in one of the state variables
then U the system is not observable and
also observability is identified by this
Matrix that's shown here which is the
observability Matrix and um the system
is observable if and only if this Matrix
is full rank hey El so small n here um
was the size of the
State uh yes and N is the size of the
state it's degrees of okay thank you
sure so now we can U go ahead and Define
the system gramians for a stable
continuous time system the reachability
grammian is uh shown by this equation
and it's actually the solution of this
leonov equation for discrete time
systems this reability gramian can be
computed using the reability Matrix um
and the system gramians are hermiss
Matrix matrices and they have real igen
values uh which means that if we um
apply igen value decomposition to the
reachability gramian its largest igen
values correspond to the uh directions
uh that are the most reachable in the
system or the stat that can be affected
by the um smallest amount of actuation
energy now keep that in mind I'll come
back to this point in a few seconds uh
similarly for a stable continuous time
system the observability gramian is
given by this equation and it's the
solution to another leonov equation for
discrete time systems this gramian can
be computed using the observability
Matrix uh the observability gramian is
also a Herm missan Matrix and its
largest a values correspond to the most
observable directions and now remember
that at the beginning of the talk I
mentioned that uh in balanc truncation
we are looking for a modal
representation uh that uh basically
orders the modes from the most
controllable and uh most observable to
the least controllable and observable um
the system gramians the reachability and
observability gramians identifies how
reachable and observable each state in
the system is and therefore we can
directly use these gramians to identify
that model representation for balanced
truncation um and another Point here is
that U instead of um uh solving these
theop equations to obtain the um system
gramians we can also obtain these
gramians by um by a data driven approach
so the reachability gramian can be
computed by the impulse response of the
direct system and the observability
gramian can be computed by the impulse
response of the ad joint system and
these are called the empirical
gramians okay so uh I guess we've
covered all the um theory that we needed
uh to lay the foundation for balance
truncation and I system realization
algorithm and at this point we can um
jump into these exciting topics so for
an um LTI system that's shown here which
represents our High Fidelity model uh in
Balance truncation we are looking for a
transformation matrix T that makes the
reachability and observability gramians
equal and diagonal or in other words
balanced uh so WP is here the
reachability gramian wo is the
observability gramian and sigma is the
is a um diagonal matrix now why do we
want to uh balance the gramians the
reason is that we want to give equal
weight to the controlability and
observability such that the states that
are difficult to reach are also
difficult to observe and we can get rid
of them because uh these states um need
a lot of actuation energy to be affected
and even if they are affected uh the
output of the system is barely sensitive
with respect to their variations so we
can just U remove those uh States uh
from the system and so as I mentioned uh
the uh reachability and observability
gramians are uh the key components of
balanc truncation so the first thing
that we do here is to compute these
gramians by solving the leop equations
um and right up front you can see that
this method can only be applied to
stable systems because these gramians
are only defined for a stable system um
uh they're not defined for unstable
systems uh and so in order to compute
the transformation matrix that balances
the gramians uh we compute the chesy
factors of the gramians uh and then SBD
of the prod product of the chesy factors
and from there we can compute the uh
balancing modes and the inverse
balancing modes that are at the end used
along with the full order model matrices
a b and c to construct their WR
matrices so the transformation matrix T
is actually um a a matrix that
transforms the system uh to coordinates
in which the most controllable modes are
also the most observable modes and in
this uh stage where we compete SBD of
the product of the cheski factors uh we
actually truncate the singular vectors
corresponding to the smallest singular
values uh because uh these singular
vectors represent the least controllable
and the least uh observable
directions um and as you can see in
order to compute the uh ROM matrices we
are directly using the full order model
matrices so the method is intrusive uh
for balance truncation we need to have
access to the RW
matrices um a powerful asp of balanced
ROMs is that uh they satisfy these error
bounds that I've shown here where G is
the transfer function of full order
model and gr is the transfer function of
the ROM um and so the ROM error is upper
bounded by the sum of the truncated
singular
values now although Balan ROMs satisfy
theoretical error bounds but there are
certain limitations that uh prevent
their application uh to to more complex
problems um uh we've already talked
about some of these uh
limitations um and at the bottom here I
have some methods uh that address each
of these U limitations and challenges
and on the right uh I have a a list of a
few sample uh references that you can
look at if you're interested in any of
these scenarios like for example if the
system is
unstable if there are a few unstable
modes in the system that you want to
um uh preserved through mod reduction
for some control purpose uh then the uh
original balance truncation method
cannot be used uh and so um under these
conditions we can for example decompose
the system into stable and unstable
subsystems we can use empirical gramians
or a partially data driven version of
balance truncation which is called the
approximate balance truncation although
these two require adjoint simulations so
if you don't have access to the Adin
system you can't use these methods and
finally the igen system realiz ation
algorithm that's the uh purely data
driven version of BT and if the system
is extremely stiff then uh the chesy
factors in the analytical balance
truncation method uh would be affected
can be affected by numerical errors and
the balance DRS can be U inaccurate and
uh in that case we would um resort to
the uh data driven versions of the of
balance truncation also if the dimension
of the system is uh more than a few
thousands uh then um Computing the
gramians with the standard method by
solving the leopon of equations would
become expensive and we should go with
methods two to five and lastly if we
don't have access to the internal
description or the governing equations
um or uh if you want to build a ROM
based on the data that comes from
experiments then u a system realization
algorithm is pretty much the only method
that we can use here so as you can see
ER is a very versatile method uh that's
basically addresses um at least all of
the limitations that I have mentioned uh
here uh but U there is no free launch uh
like any other datadriven method uh the
performance of RA ROMs uh depends on the
training data that we use for them so um
ra ROMs do not necessarily satisfy the
theoretical error bounds given by by the
analytical balance truncation and um uh
that's why we should be very careful
about the sampling properties when we
want to collect training data uh from
for the ER
ROMs so now the ion system realization
algorithm is originally a system
identification method uh that uh uses
the external description of the system
to build a minimum realization uh for
the U for the system uh and it has
strong connections with a balance
truncation method which is why it's
considered the non-intrusive data driven
version of balance
truncation so considering this uh this
Creet time system which is our full
order model then we have the Handel
Matrix here uh that we have already seen
before uh and byi is the sequence of
Markov parameters or the impulse
response of the system and each
subsequent Row in this Handel Matrix is
constructed by uh Shifting the um
impulse response one step forward in
time and despite I've uh written this uh
sequence of markof parameters in terms
of the system matrices but not that this
is a completely data driven process and
we don't need access to the um full
order model matrices at all so the next
thing that we do is to compute another
Matrix uh which is called the shifted
hanel Matrix and this uh Matrix is
obtained by uh Shifting the entire hanel
Matrix one step forward in time now this
may remind people of dynamic mode
decomposition uh we'll talk about the
connections of RA with DMD in the next
slide um so then we use the uh shifted
Handel Matrix along with the singular
values and singular vectors of the
Handel Matrix to build their own
matrices and as you can see there are no
ABC matrices in these equations uh
because the method is non- intrusive and
we don't need access to the uh full
order model matrices or any adjoint s
simulations unlike the approximate um
balance tration method and therefore
even if the data comes from experiments
we can still use this
method
now for those of you who are familiar
with Dynamic mode decomposition it's
shown in this paper that ra is directly
related to DMD U so if we apply DMD to H
and H Prime instead of the usual
snapshots matrices a Tilda is here the
linear operator given by dndd uh and if
we compare this uh linear operator
against the Dynamics Matrix given by ra
we can see that the two matrices are
related with a similarity transform H so
their a values are the same and their
igen vectors are related so we can as
well use ra to compute the DMD
modes okay um so now I guess we can um
uh see some results of application of
the a system realization algorithm to
our two numerical experiments and also
talk about some uh practical aspects of
um of
ER so the first uh example that we are
uh we are going to look at is a
one-dimensional reacting flow uh problem
that's governed by the onedimensional
nav stes equations with uh species
transport and reaction that are shown
here we solve these equations with the
finite volume approach using the second
order Road scheme and du all time time
stepping and in order to solve these
equations we have used an open- source
code that's developed in our group uh
this framework is called perform which
stands for prototyping environment for
reacting the order reduction uction
methods and uh it's basically a package
that uh provides multiple Benchmark
problems including one-dimensional
reacting for problems that can be used
and to test model reduction techniques
and uh it also comes with multiple um
model reduction uh capabilities
including uh different projection based
model reduction methods with Hyper
reduction and linear and nonlinear
dimensionality reduction method so the
code is available in this uh giab repo
along with a complete
uh documentation and the capabilities of
the uh full order model and the ROM in
the
code so we solve the nonlinear full
order model subject to characteristic
boundary conditions and this table um
shows some of the specifics U uh and uh
we obtain a steady state Solution that's
shown here in these plots which
represents a standing flame at the
vicinity of the uh domain so this is
pressure this is velocity this is
temperature and this is species Mass
fraction and then we linearize the uh
equations about this steady state
solution to get a linear set of
equations that we then use to uh build
the ER
RS so this is our uh linear full order
model here where J is the jauan Matrix
evaluated at the steady state solution
and Q is the vector of primitive
variables and B contains the boundary
flux as U is our input uh this plot here
shows the I values of the full order
model all of the values are in the left
side of the complex plane and and so the
system is stable now what's challenging
about this application is the extreme
stiffness of the system due to the
presence of a chemical Source term so
the uh condition number of the jauan
Matrix is in the order of 10 to13 which
as I said uh it will introduce numerical
errors in the tesy factors in the
analytical balance truncation and that's
why we resorted to the data driven
version of balanced truncation here so
uh we uh trained the ER ROMs uh by uh by
applying unit impulse to the system we
are applying unit impulse uh to the back
pressure through the uh characteristic
boundary conditions at the downstream of
the domain uh and we collect the
snapshots these PLS show the norm of the
state for pressure velocity temperature
and species Mass fraction and as you can
see uh this system has a lightly damped
impulse response which means that uh
there is a there's an AR Vector in the
system that takes a long time to uh die
out and uh that makes construction ofs
uh more complex because uh we need to
capture enough samples to we need to
collect enough samples to capture the
decay of this I vector and that results
in a larger handil Matrix and that is
harder to uh work with so we do that and
then and this uh plot here shows the U
singular values U the decay of the
singular values of the and kill Matrix
uh 77 pressure and velocity modes 50
temperature and 19 Mass fraction modes
capture
99.99% of the input output
energy um so we construct the ROMs and
this plot here shows the I values of the
ROM um all of them are stable but U note
that the time step of the ra ROM is two
orders of magnitude larger than the time
step of the full order model so if we
run the full order model with the same
time step as the ROM it will be un table
which is what these uh red circles show
and on the right uh we are comparing the
Reconstruction of the impulse response
by the ROM against the full order model
which shows perfect match but we are
more interested in the predictive
performance of ROMs because at the end
of the day that's the ultimate goal of
model reduction so um uh we have trained
the RS with unit impulse and we are here
testing it with a completely different
input which is the sinodal input with a
frequency of 215 k
Kilz uh so ignoring these discrepancies
at the right side for a few seconds we
can see that in the uh rest of the
domain the ROM solution perfectly
matches the full order model now why do
we have these discrepancies here let's
look at uh these uh plots on the left
which show the impulse response at an
early time step as you can see as the
impulse enters the domain from the right
side uh there are very sharp gradients
close to the uh right boundary that
attenuate as the impulse propagates in
the domain and apparently the sampling
frequency uh that we used during
collection of training data for ER ROMs
was not sufficient to capture these uh
sharp gradients and that's why these
discrepancies appear at the right side
of the domain through prediction uh but
um this is challenging because as as I
mentioned the system already has a
likely damped impulse response so we
needed to uh capture a lot of um collect
a lot of snapshots to capture that and
um we cannot afford to further increase
the sampling frequency in the entire
domain uh to capture those sharp
gradients and that's why we came up with
a simple output domain decomposition
method to resolve these gradients
without the need to uh increase the
sampling uh frequency in the entire
domain I'll talk about that later but
before that um we did some tests uh to
compare the ra ROMs against the uh
projection based ROMs specifically the P
gin ROM in this slide where the P modes
are trained with the same impulse
response snapshots as the ER ROMs and
then the ROM is being tested with the
same codal input that I talked about in
the previous slide so these uh plots
here show uh the probe measurements for
a probe located at the vicinity of the
flame the black line is the ROM and the
red line is the full order model and as
you can see the ROM is not doing a good
job at all in prediction and then this
encouraged us to further compare uh ra
against these sares pet gallin as well
uh so here the projection based ROMs are
trained with um combined snapshots with
perturbations with frequencies of 200
210 and 220 khz and then tested with uh
with a with an intermediate frequency of
215 khz and these PLS show the relative
error computed based on the full order
model solution q and the ROM solution Q
had so as you can see the black line
shows the ra ROM which is the best then
the blue line is the P gin ROM and these
three lines are for the the squares pet
gurin we have multiple lines because
lspg is U sensitive with respect to time
step and we wanted to try different time
steps so as you can see none of these
projection based ROMs are able to
compete against ER for this linear
system and so let's return again uh to
the the problem that we had at the right
side of the uh boundary with the um
sharp
gradients um so I said that we didn't
want to increase the sampling frequency
in the entire domain because that would
give us a huge handle Matrix that's hard
to work with uh so we uh use this output
domain decomposition idea so consider
the uh discrete Time full order model
here the idea is to decompose the output
uh Matrix output map output Matrix C uh
into three blocks where each block is
used by a different ROM separately
that's why we have ROM one ROM two and
ROM three so each of these ROMs is
trained uh with um impulse response
snapshots collected with a different
sampling frequency uh r one that has the
lowest sampling frequency covers the
majority of the computational domain and
rree that has the highest sampling
frequency uh covers only the um five um
rightmost cells of the domain that's
where we had the sh sharpest gradients
um and so although round three uh has
many more markup parameters compared to
round one but the number of rows in the
Handel Matrix of round three is one
order smaller than r one um and so uh we
are basically from moving from the left
side of the domain to the right side of
the domain we are increasing the
sampling frequency while maintaining
computational efficiency as much as we
can and then we used another method to
further reduce the size of the handil
Matrix this is called tangential
interpolation uh which is developed for
multi-input multi-output systems to
reduce the uh number of inputs and
outputs before construction of the
Handel Matrix so what we do is that we
first assemble the impulse response in
two different ways as can be seen in
Theta L and Theta R then we apply SVD to
each of these two matrices separately
and the singular vectors of theta L are
the uh left tangential modes W1 that
represent the um low dimensional output
space and the singular vectors of theta
R are the right right tangential modes
of W2 that represent the uh low
dimensional input space and so what we
do is that we go ahead and uh project
the impulse response onto these um input
and output subspaces to get y hat and we
use y hat instead to construct the
Handel Matrix and we follow the same
standard procedure for construction of
RA ROMs but at the end we're going to
need to lift the ra ROM matrices back to
the original High dimensional input
output
space so we use these methods uh in our
application and this table shows the
offline cost um of um ra ROMs with and
without tangential interpolation as uh
as you can see the tangential
interpolation method has reduced the
offline cost by a factor of around 1.7
and uh in the uh online phase
uh the online wall clock time of the ER
ROM is uh 116 and uh which which
basically gives us two orders of
magnitude reduction in computation time
compared to the full order model and at
the bottom we have the Rong predictions
uh for this case where there there is no
trace of those discrepancies at the
right side of the uh domain
anymore so next we uh decided to apply
ra to a slightly more complex problem
the goal here is to uh use ra ROMs to
predict a acoustic response of an air
foil uh so for this example we have a
subsonic flow A5 flow over an air foil
and we are pering the entire farfield
boundary to model atmospheric turbulence
and then uh we are aiming to predict the
um acoustic response of the air foil as
the perturbations propagate and interact
in the domain uh so uh to that end we
first run the full order the Hy
simulations uh which are based on the
two- dimensional Oiler equations here uh
we use a fin out volume approach with a
second order row scheme to solve the
equation subject to characteristic
boundary
conditions uh so we generate a steady
state solution and then we uh project
the equations we U linearize the
equations about that stady state
solution to get a linear set of
equations here that's used to build the
ra ROMs here J is The jauan Matrix and Q
Prime is the perturbation
field now I'd like to mention a few
practical points about application of RA
in this U example and and also in
general um so although theoretically uh
we um U train ER ROMs uh by the response
of the system to unit impulse but in
practice depending on your application a
unit impulse may not even be physical or
it may not be um effective for example
in this application we have a subsonic
flow uh and so a unit impulse would mean
that we need to set Mark number along
the farfield boundary to one which is
not even consistent with our problem
setup and um on the other hand we
realize that in this application
applying an impulsive input in a single
time step um is not effective and we
need to apply that input um for a longer
time uh to actually affect affect the
system uh and so that's why we decided
to perturb the uh velocity along uh the
entire farfield boundary with a gaan
shaped input and another point is that
as I mentioned we need to uh perer the
entire farfield boundary in this case uh
so we have a multi-input multi- output
system which means that we need to
perturb each cell um along the farfield
boundary to collect a separate sequence
of markof parameters um and assemble all
of those Markoff parameters in one
Handel Matrix and proceed there and
proceed to construction of er ROMs from
there um so for example if we have a 400
by 100 grid we're going to have
6004 uh cells or input channels along
the farfield boundary for this
application uh and and therefore we need
to per each of those Channel or each of
those 6004 channels separately to
collect the training data uh which is
apparently very expensive uh so as the
grid becomes finer uh the number of uh
sales along the field boundary increases
and the offline cost of construction of
RA ROMs uh becomes uh prohibitive and
that's why we uh came up with an idea
based on the gapy Pod approach uh to
basically uh reduce the number of uh
input channels along the far forefield
boundary uh and and therefore the
offline cost of construction of er ROMs
uh we did so many tests you can find the
results in this paper but in the
interest of time uh I just just uh
directly jump into the gapy p idea so
gapy p is a method that is usually used
for um Spar sensing and uh construction
of entire flow fields from Spar sensor
measurements and also for hyper
reduction in reduced order models um and
the um General procedure for gapy pod is
that we first compute a set of modes for
example Purity modes based on a set of
St training data uh that are collected
in Matrix Q here so Q can be
approximated by linear combination of P
pi and and a is here the modal
coefficients um s is an observation
Matrix that basically contains our um
sparse sensor measurements and P is a uh
permutation Matrix that um basically
identifies the the elements chooses the
elements of Q and f that correspond to
the sensor locations and the go goal
here is to reconstruct the entire flow
field from the sparse sensor
measurements now the question is um how
do we know where should we locate those
um sensors in order to get maximum
reconstruction accuracy and that that
question is answered in this paper and
also some earlier Works um and it's
shown in this paper that the optimal uh
location of the sensors is given uh by
the um pivot locations when we apply QR
factorization with column pivoting to
The Matrix of pod modes and this is for
the case where the desired number of
sensors is equal to the uh number of
retained modes and for the over sample
case we should apply QR factorization to
five5
transpose and so having the uh optimal
sensor locations and the sensor
measurements in s and also the P modes
then we can solve an inverse problem to
obtain the uh model coefficients and
from there we can reconstruct the uh
flow field and so we have um basically
adapted this um algorithm for actuator
selection and in our case uh our goal is
basically to use this algorithm to
identify the most critical input
channels along the farfield boundary for
training the ER
RS uh so the general procedure is very
similar to The Standard method uh but
our training data is different our
training data is basically the markup
sequences corresponding to all of the
input channels that are computed using
the course a course grid uh so the whole
idea here is to avoid running the um
full order model in the high resolution
grid uh to obtain the markup sequences
for all of the input channels so we
instead run the full order model in a
corser grid and collect the training
data for gapy pod and this label
compares the dimensions of uh these
matrices in our implementation of the
method against the standard gapo
method and so q that that contains our
training data here is p by m where p is
the total number of aerators and M is
the number of snapshots s the
observation Matrix is p which is
actually not the observation Matrix but
uh PS by m where PS is the desired
number of actuators and P is the
permutation matrix it's PS by P and um a
hat is similar to The Standard uh
approach so then we take um uh this um
algorithm and reconstruct the markof
sequence although note that uh we are
not using the Reconstruction of markof
sequence by gapy P at all here the only
thing that we need from this algorithm
is the location of the most critical
input channels along the farfield
boundary uh that uh we want to use in
order to train in in order to uh perturb
only those channels in the uh full order
model that is run in the finer
grid
uh so we use this method for our 400 by
100 grid where we have a total of 604
input channels along the farfield
boundary and uh gapy P gives uh the
optimal location for 150 input channels
uh that we only preser those channels to
collect markof sequences to train the ra
ROMs and then we also use a tangential
interpolation to further reduce the size
of the Handel Matrix and the sa show
shows the number of retained left and
right tangential modes and also their
arm Dimension um note that the left
modes represent a reduction from 40,000
output channels and the right modes
represent a reduction from 100 and
originally 600 150 and original 600 for
uh input channels so uh that reduction
is Major uh and the left plot here shows
the decay of singular values U of the
Handel Matrix and the right plot shows
the AR values of the ER ROMs that are
stable so now we'd like to um evaluate
the predictive performance of the ROMs
by um trying different types of inputs
that are not seen during the training so
we we have trained the ra ROMs by the
gaan shaped input and uh here we are
using the sinos soidal input and
perturbing uh velocity U along um at all
604 channels along the farit boundary
simultaneously and these plots here show
the probe measurements for probe that is
located at the bottom of the airf uh so
uh besides some discrepancies in the
amplitude of the V component of velocity
we can see that the uh ROM um agrees
very well with the full order model and
this is also shown in these in this
snapshot of the pressure perturbation
Contour uh where the left one is the
full order model and the right one is
the uh ROM so we decided to test a a
more complex U input sign signal which
is this triangle wave this sharp
Radiance and um uh looking at the probe
measurements uh there are some
discrepancies in the U components of
velocity but overall the ROMs are uh
correctly picking up the Dynamics in
response to a more challenging input
Channel as well and the last input
signal that we tried uh was a
non-periodic step input that we applied
to the entire parfield boundary all uh
6004 channels not only uh the channels
are identified by gapy pod and U again
we can still see that the ROM is
replicating the Dynam dynamics of the
full order model very well uh so that's
for the accuracy of the reduced order
models regarding U computational savings
this table gives us some information
about the online and offline
computational savings the line
linearization of the full order model uh
gave us an order of magnitude reduction
uh in uh computation time for each Mark
of sequence the low Fidelity gapy pod
approach reduce the number of input
channels by a factor of four and
therefore the computation time of the
training data by 353 hours and
unfortunately we were not able to uh
compute an online an offline speed up
Factor because uh without the gapy Pod
method uh constructing the ER ROMs was
uh beyond our computational resources
and at the in the online phase uh the ER
ROM gave us a speed up factor of
258 and so uh we went through a long
journey in the past 50 minutes almost 50
minutes uh the takeaway message messages
are that um a system realization
algorithm is a non-intrusive data driven
version of balance truncation that
addresses uh many of the limitations of
this method in application to more
complex problems although the Dan side
is that like any other data driven
method the performance of er ROMs
depends on the training data and so we
should be careful about the sampling
properties to train erra ROMs but if if
trained properly ra RS can operate in a
purely predicting predictive scenario
and uh looking at the applications uh we
also said that um sampling the impulse
response sufficiently could be
challenging because it may increase the
offline cost of construction of er ROMs
for example when the U system has a
lifely damped impulse response or sharp
gradients that need higher sampling
frequencies and also in systems with
many inputs and input and output
channels also uh the cost of RA uh
increases and then we U uh introduced
some additional methods to reduce the
offline cost like the tangential
interpolation method a domain
decomposition approach and also a low
Fidelity version of the gapy P method
for actuator selection um and lastly uh
there um topics that could be uh pursued
further um as as future work would be
for example application of RA to larger
scale problems and coming up with ideas
to further decrease the offline cost of
er ROMs and also improving upon the
existing algorithms for RA in time
varying and nonlinear systems which is
also something that uh we are currently
working on and with that I'd like to
open the floor for any questions thank
you thank you so much for the wonderful
talk um very informal talk and I Lear L
about the balance tration ah great uh
yes let's let's have a Q&A
session um I can start um I have a
clarification question if you go to
slide 35 if you don't mind um
35 yeah and you compare the LSP and
color Okay P there um you apply the LSP
and gin to linearized P model yes that's
correct okay because they can be applied
to nonlinear yes of course yeah but we
wanted them to be consistent with the ER
round so we apply them to the uh
linearized full order model here I see
so and and when the conclusion like the
story you you're telling in this slide
is when it when it is applied to the
linear uh problem Ela can outperform in
terms of accuracy both lspg and color
can uh yes so um since ER is basically
the datadriven version of balance
truncation it's it's able to uh perform
in a purely predictive setting where the
uh input signal is not uh seen during
the train in the training data uh while
the U projection based ROMs are not able
to perform as well as ER in in such a
truly predictive setting without U
having observed that uh
perturbation um well there are there are
ways of parameterizing the G in p and
lspg not sure you have applied those no
no we are here using the standard
projection based model reduction methods
so we are basically comparing erra to
the standard um methods okay not not the
variant like the parametric all right um
we do have a question um in chat room
Kevin asked
okay he has a few questions for future
Milestones first what would Europe
approach be toward unsteady n linear
problem and second question is how can
it be extended toward a more generic
input than a linear
actuator so he basically has a two
questions right um so for linear
problems um for nonlinear problems I
mean that's the million dollar question
although there have been some efforts uh
like for example for weekly nonlinear
problems uh some people directly apply
uh the uh same balance tration algorithm
um and also there have been some recent
efforts using um uh um again methods
that stem from the approximate balance
truncation mainly uh using covariance
balancing for example um but I I haven't
seen any methods that apply uh ER ROMs
to nonlinear problems it has been in the
same direction as approximate balance
truncation but not the a system
realization algorithm because they are
different you know because approximate
balance truncation uh is kind of
partially data driven we still need
access to the full order model operators
and adjoint system simulations but
balance tration is but ra is purely data
driven
and second question was how can it be
extended for the more generic input than
a linear
actuator uh well at least for the
problems that uh we have considered here
um any type of input that we have used
uh works on these problems um so I think
uh if the ROMs are trained properly any
type of input that you use uh would be
um would result in accurate RS
thank you um um I have another question
about the Gap P that that you introduced
I don't know it was a slide 42 43 or
something like that um when I heard that
first I thought you you use the G pod um
to reduce the parameter dimensionality
course the as you you know refine the M
on the boundary U the number of
parameters increases you know crazy and
high dimensional parameter space it's
it's is really hard to um deal with in
the data driven approach in general so
you try to use the dimensionality of the
parameters bace on Gap using gpod that
that was what I my my understanding but
up to in this slide you're you're doing
something different I mean you apply you
run the um the simulation course agreed
and then yes that's right uh yes so we
are uh running the simulations um over
the cors grade to collect the training
data for Gap p and then uh we are uh
using the optimal uh actuator locations
given by the PB QR factorization with uh
column pivoting in gap P to identify the
most critical input channels which means
the input channels that affect the uh
markof sequence uh the
most okay um
great I guess my understanding was
somewh correct then um how many how many
you know indices do you extract um PP is
yes so we are um um um so PS here is the
desired number of uh actuator locations
we have considered
150 uh input channels so we are reducing
from uh the uh original 604 input
channels uh to 50 input
channels I see okay so that that
definitely helps on the um yes so as as
I said this uh basically reduces the uh
cost of uh construction generation of
the training data by 353 hours okay all
right sounds
good okay any other questions from
audience you can unmute yourself and ask
questions
don't be
shy
um well if not let's thank our speaker
today uh elas for the wonderful talk and
and it it was very informal talk and I
learned a lot um from you um thank you
so much Dr CH and everyone else great
speaker um well that um you know
concludes the today's seminar uh let's
thank our our speaker
elas um one more time and um I think the
next ddps seminar is Tuesday next week
um which will be a hybrid uh so if
you're on site then you can actually
come in person so um hope to see you
there um all right thank you El ni
thanks